in Paraguay history continues to repeat
itself despite a bitter campaign against
the central left Coalition that at one
point looked set to win a Conservative
candidate is again going to be president
Santiago Pena heads the conservative
party that's dominated politics for 70
out of 75 years
I'm 70 years old I was born and grew up
with Colorado party and they're going to
have to put up with us for another five
years I think that Santiago Pena is
capable and I hope he corrects the
defect vices that we have
something
the 44 year old Economist and former
Finance Minister promises better days
ahead for one of South America's Least
developed countries in part because of
rampant corruption
democracy is my flag but democracy with
bread because in abject poverty it's
neither democracy nor freedom thank you
my dear Colorado party we will honor you
until the last second of my
Administration
Santiago Pena is definitely the man of
the hour but so is the former president
oracio partes whom nobody had seen for
days he had been keeping very very quiet
low profile especially because the
United States government has accused him
and the former vice president of having
lynched to International drug
trafficking now he has come out of the
shadows and is being embraced by the
next president Santiago Pena
Pena one with just under 43 percent of
the votes well ahead of his closest
rival Ephraim Allegre lamented that he
would have won had the opposition been
more united
despite its own bitter infighting the
Colorado party operates as a solid block
he controls the the other the whole
state apparatus
public officers are mostly from the
Colorado party around 80 to 90 percent
and this is like a big
big advantage that puts the field in a
very asymmetric position for the
oppositional parties
perhaps that explains why paraguayans
are hoping for a better future while
again voting for the party of the past
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Asuncion
Paraguay